chacun voit midi bien différemment aux
portes de l'entreprise il faut dire que
l'enjeu est de taille avec cette brèche
possible sur le front des 35 heures si
un accord était signé passer de 35 à 37
heures 45 par semaine beaucoup y met des
bémols voire un refus catégorique
cette fois la direction porterait
l'effort salariale de 2 8 à 3,1
accompagné d' un plan d'embauché de 75
personnes sur trois ans et d'un
investissement de 20 millions d'euros
est-ce que cet accord va suffire à
rendre pérennes l'activité sur le site
est fait par des salariés psa donc c'est
la vraie question de base à laquelle il
faut qu'on s'attache et il n'y a pas que
le fait de travailler plus et gagner un
peu plus
il ya aussi un plan d'investissement il
faut qu'on voie de l' embauche il faut
qu'ils aient puisé ses réalisations
qu'on enlève cette chape de plomb de
pouvoir est un jour soit une filiale
souhaite il faut qu'on garde le travail
pour nous ça la rep et ça ça c'est
l'essentiel
mais ce sera le débat avec les salariés
pour la cgt augmentation et garanties
sont largement insuffisantes
complètement insuffisant parce qu'on est
encore sur le travail gratuit
et comme disait salariés on veut bien
nous forcer à travailler plus mais il
faut nous payer non pas les pas assurés
non plus puisque les 150 suppressions de
postes il ya les plans perdure et en
échange nous propose 25 cdi
psa par an et on compte pas les 124
postes supplémentaires qui vont manquer
lié à l'augmentation du temps de travail
le compte n'y est pas les prochaines
réunions de négociation ont été fixées
au 5 et 11 juin